hey 42 here the royal family are
famously long-lived Her Majesty looks
fantastic for 93 and is still almost as
active in her duties as ever the Philip
will be a hundred in under two years
time and he's still relatively sprightly
in fact he's deferred longest-lived
British royal ever only surpassed by the
Queen Mother who lived to 101 and Alice
who lived to 102 considering the average
life expectancy in the UK is 80 years
and that's not bad going sure thousands
of us normal people regularly achieve
these ages are much older so what's the
big deal well that's true but for such a
large majority of the same family to
consistently reach old age is extremely
rare and it's not just the current
generation the British royal family has
always exceeded the average populations
lifespan throughout history
why is there perhaps something in the
royal blood after all excluding
executions and murders between the 16th
and 18th centuries the Habsburgs had an
average lifespan of roughly 55 years the
French monarchy had an average of 51
years yet between the same period the
English and then British monarchy it
switched over in 1707 had an impressive
average lifespan of 63 years and this
was a time when bleeding to balance of
person's humors were still the most
frequently used remedy by physicians
what was so special about the British
monarchy well historically
there is no obvious reason why the
British monarchy should have achieved
higher average lifespans and their
friends and Austrian counterparts they
lived very similar luxurious lifestyles
and all had access to the very same
medical treatments if you could even
call them treatments the sample sizes
are very small here these averages are
each derived from less than 10 total
monarchs per monarchy so the most likely
answer is
sixteenth and eighteenth century British
monarchs just got lucky
nits and anomaly one thing is clear
though historically monarchs live longer
than pretty much everyone else the
average lifespan in England between 16
and 18 centuries was roughly 40 years
which is significantly lower than the 63
years achieved by royalty there were two
primary reasons for this disparity
firstly only a king ate like a king the
variety and volume of food available to
an English monarch was unrivaled by any
other citizen even the wealthiest
aristocracy in the lands did not eat as
well as the king surprisingly with a
couple of notable exceptions very few
English monarchs abused this food
overload to gorge themselves into
obesity what they did get out of it
however was a wide assortment of
vitamins fiber and protein that the vast
majority of other people could only
dream of consuming not that they were
consciously aware of the health benefits
anyway the second quality of an English
monarch that helped them survive longer
was the very fact that they rarely came
into contact with other people the Kings
purposely kept a small circle of
confidence that this kept their secrets
better contained and reduced the
likelihood of assassination attempts but
more pertinently
meant less exposure to pathogens the
closest contact they had within this
circle was with their groom of the stool
whose sole job was to wipe their ass but
for longevity keeping a small social
circle is a food by not coming into
contact with those god-awful peasants
roaming about one's country a monic
vastly reduced her likelihood of
contracting disease which was
persistently rife it all goes without
saying but the hygiene standards were
significantly higher inside a royal
palace than the average town house or
village tavern for example it was common
for English inns in the Middle Ages to
lay down an interior floor of dung
it was straw fast-forwarding a few
hundred years how does one explain the
longevity of the current generation of
British royalty after all today in
developed nations the hygiene gap
between the poorest in society and the
richest is almost non-existent perhaps a
closer look at the life inside the
households and lifestyle of the various
members of the royal family can
illuminate the cause of their vitality
for a start physical exercise is
strongly encouraged in nopales from a
young age royal aides and their family
instill impressionable young Royals with
a love for the countryside and sports
such as horse riding polo shooting and
skiing Prince Phillip has always been
praised for his ferociously active
lifestyle he has always been a lover of
polo but had to retire at 50 he kept up
his horse riding though until only very
recently the entire royal family enjoys
frequent walks throughout their various
generously proportioned lands when the
Queen takes her annual summer holiday to
Balmoral in Scotland she reportedly
enjoys a rather lengthy stroll through
the grounds every morning considering
she has a bagpiper playing outside her
bedroom window at 9 a.m. every morning
I'm not bloody surprised she probably
goes for a walk to find him and kill him
not only do they all get frequent
exercise but they all have access to the
best medical care in the world the royal
family all have regular health
screenings carried out by London's
leading private physicians these
screenings include prostate checks for
men breast examinations and mammograms
for women a diabetes tests blood tests
and general health checks for blood
pressure cholesterol and of a warning
signals whilst these annual checks may
seem insignificant to uni they are
actually a significant contributing
factor to the longevity of the Royals
because many of the world's biggest
killers cancer diabetes heart disease
are all somewhat preventable or
manageable if the warning signs are
detected early not
for example it's thought that 50 to 80%
of deaths from cardiovascular disease
are preventable annual health screenings
really can't significantly extend your
life but the unfortunate truth is that a
tiny tiny percentage of the population
goes for an annual checkup usually
because of the associated costs although
the NHS in Britain offers a free health
check every five years for anyone aged
40 to 74 yet only 44 percent of people
take up this offer the Queen has a
personal doctor who holds the official
title physician to the Queen to deal
with small sniffles and mild illness
medical assistance is never more than a
whisper away while she is on overseas
tours a senior royal navy physician
accompanies her who is granted to the
honorary title medical officer to the
Queen and when the Royals do get sick
well laid-out simply pop alums at a
local NHS hospital and get put on a
three-month waiting list you perhaps
wouldn't realize walking past its plain
entrance but down s unassuming Melbourne
streets in central London is the most
exclusive hospital in Britain King
Edward the seventh Hospital Princess
Margaret died within these walls the
Queen had knee surgery here Prince
Phillip recently had a knee operation
here and it has treated countless of her
Royals you can guarantee of a royal
falls ill this is probably where they'll
be whisked off to the hospital claims at
least four nurses per patient at all
times industry-leading surgeons and
cutting-edge medical equipment it also
has a very well-stocked library for
patients to browse and one of London's
few hydrotherapy pools generally the
Royals are known to eat a varied and
balanced diet consisting of
exceptionally high quality ingredients
and almost never eat processed food but
the Queen takes healthy eating more
seriously than perhaps any of a family
member she has a strict no start rule
when eating on her own she never eats
bread
potatoes rice or pasta with lunch or
dinner it is well known that she
absolutely adores fresh fish and eats it
almost every single day without fail her
typical daily lunch is grilled fish
served of wilted spinach or grilled
cause yet in evenings she is served
either venison beef pheasant or salmon
all of which is farmed shot or caught on
her own lands usually are moral or
Sandringham most of the time that meat
is cooked at a Gaelic sauce made from
whiskey cream and mushrooms it's also
reported that one of her favorite meals
is duck a L'Orange the Queen may stay
away from starches at lunch and dinner
time but she is not frightened of a bit
of cake when it comes to sweet treats
her Majesty is fully committed
she starts every morning with a pre
breakfast pot of Earl Grey and a few
biscuits
she likes McVitie's rich tea and she
takes afternoon tea every single day
every afternoon she has a selection of
finger sandwiches containing cucumber
egg and mayonnaise Haman mustard or
smoked salmon and cream cheese then she
has scones followed by a selection of
cakes such as honey and cream
ginger and fruit Her Majesty the Queen
is also rather fond of a daily dose of
alcohol every day before lunch she
enjoys a glass of gin mixed with a
French sweet wine called Dubonnet and
every night she has a glass of champagne
and some chocolates before bed yes
that's right
what the Royals eat and their active
lifestyle certainly play a huge part in
their longevity obviously gin and
champagne is the answer but they may
also be benefiting from very healthy
genetics it used to be scientific
consensus that genetics alone was
responsible for roughly 30% of a
person's life span however recent
research estimates it to be more like 7%
so for everyone 7% of how long you live
which is no small amounts can be
attributed solely to their DNA so if
your parents grandparents and
great-grandparents
have a record of living well into old
age and avoiding age-related illnesses
such as stroke and dementia then you too
will have a small lifespan boost
compared to your peers thanks for
watching I've recently launched my first
book it's called sticker flock in it a
thousand years of bizarre history from
Britain and beyond
if you'd like to get your hands on a
first edition signed copy then head on
over to unbound publishing the links in
the description and pledge today thank
you